Speaker 1: All right, everybody, it's time
for the most awaited and sometimes most dreaded
moment of the week, it's time for the mailbag.
Email us info at David Pakman dot com.
Spammers and people who abuse the email just
get auto filtered into the trash.
It's a sad thing, but it does happen.
Some people email us every day, multiple times
a day.
Don't do it.
Nobody's going to read it.
It'll just get you banned.
Let's just jump right in, though, because
there are messages that I would not describe
as being messages of peace and love.
User No B.S. wrote in and said, Why don't
you go back to Argentina and complain about
your own country and start a show to divide
it?
You're a weak, pathetic baiter male who sold
his soul and show for a leftist organization
for money.
You're an perfect example.
That's right.
You're an perfect example of everything that
is wrong with the world today.
Satan is your daddy.
I take issue with the fact that we sold the
show for a leftist organization or to a leftist
organization for money.
Many have claimed we are Soros funded.
It's thinly veiled anti-Semitism, guys.
People claim we're funded by the DNC.
I'm not even a Democrat.
The DNC has never, never given us anything,
just for once, putting the xenophobia of go
back to Argentina aside for a moment, just
for once.
I would love to see a single one of these
claims backed up with even a scintilla.
Of data.
I'm ready to hear it.
If you've got it to present next one this
this is a bonus from Facebook.
I love this.
This one actually has a big back story.
Someone wrote to me and said, Cut your show
today, and it's all entirely opinion, not
news, just f.
Now, a lot of people write this because they
have such lack of media literacy that they
seem to think.
I believe I do a news show now, as all of
you know, if you've been listening to the
show or watching it for any period of time,
you know that I accurately.
Characterize this program as an opinion show.
This is an opinion show, and if any of you
have seen my sort of knowledge pyramid where
if we want to be informed about the world,
shows like mine should be equivalent to the
junk food.
They're more entertainment that hopefully
gives you ideas, informs you, gets you thinking
we need to have at the bottom of our pyramid.
It's funny, you know, it's sort of the opposite
of of like religious doctrine where it's like,
we have the answers.
It's the opposite of Trump saying I alone
can fix it.
My view is we should all have as a baseline
epistemology, critical thinking, media literacy
and philosophy.
That's our baseline that then allows us to
go and read and learn about history and political
science.
We take our knowledge of knowledge and we
go and we study these areas history, economics,
all these different things.
The next quad piece of the pyramid is news
reporting, actual reports, Associated Press,
et cetera.
And then after all that once you're well-versed
in knowing, how did I know, how do I come
to know the things I believe and studying
what has happened in the past and economic
theory and seeing what's going on?
Then you throw commentary and opinion programs
that you like.
On top of that.
That's always been my position.
It's almost like I'm trying to put myself
out of business.
But then he goes, It's funny when someone
writes in and goes, Your program is not news,
it's opinion.
I thought you should know that.
Oh, believe me, I know the fact that so many
people don't know is the problem we have in
this country.
Next to is from Don and Don wrote in about
COVID deaths.
Don said, Dear David, please refrain from
your weekly reports on notable unvaccinated
people dying from COVID.
Any fool can point out that many fully vaccinated
people also have died from COVID, and your
one sided exuberance makes you appear petty
and thoughtless.
I have never been exuberant about unvaccinated
people dying from COVID, bring that to some
other show done because that's a garbage allegation
in every segment, I say.
For me, these aren't funny segments.
These are not, I don't this isn't good.
So tell us someone else goes on to say, you
may not care, and perhaps you receive all
critique as being some political assault,
but you really should take a moment and think
about how your well-earned reputation as a
reasonable commenter can become solid.
Yours truly don.
Well, Don, if you were making a criticism
that was connected to the facts that I'm exuberant
about these people dying, that would be one
thing.
As I've said before, yes, vaccinated people
sometimes die.
Your likelihood of dying if you are fully
vaccinated is orders of magnitude lower than
if you are not.
And the reason that we point out these stories
is the defiance with which some of these people
say, I don't need to worry only exists among
the anti-vaxxers.
The people who go and get vaccinated recognize,
even if I'm not likely to get very sick, I
want the protection.
Why did I go and get my three doses?
Because I'm not likely to get very sick, but
why chance it?
I wear my seatbelt.
I use winter tires.
I would take the suit of armor if I walk through
a forest with arrows flying.
And so the point here is the defiance with
which to the very end, they continue to spread
anti-vax and then they die and they are unvaccinated.
I completely take issue with the characterization
from Don, Todd wrote in about the last week.
We looked at this segment where a an anti-vax
right winger, model, actress type person said
that when she goes near vaccinated people,
she has rectal bleeding.
And I said that could be very serious.
Todd wrote in and said, Pacman, I've researched
the strange anal bleeding the poor woman is
experiencing when around vaccinated people.
My research concludes It's a new form of stigmata.
If you wear this on your show, please don't
play pizza's here or we have Kentucky Fried
Chicken in the background.
I don't know.
I don't even know what that means.
But yet if I googled stigmata, I didn't know
what it was.
Apparently, it's various sores and bleeding
considered to be associated with some kind
of religious belief.
It's some kind of punishment, some stick stigmatize,
like if for sinning or something or Satan,
someone does it anyway.
It's yeah.
Given that many of these people are Christians,
you would think maybe they would.
They would chalk it up to two stigmata.
Got another message?
Alexa has decided it doesn't like David Pakman
greetings for the last few days asking Alexa
to play The David Pakman Show.
The latest episode brings up techno music.
I listened to it for a couple of minutes yesterday
to make sure you hadn't changed your opening
music unless you are opening with an extended
cut.
I think the Alexa programing has gotten screwed
up.
I don't use Slash have Alexa if anybody in
the audience can replicate this.
If you can get a video of asking Alexa to
play the latest episode and it playing techno,
please record it and send it to info at David
Pakman dot com.
We would really like to see that that that
sounds absolutely hilarious.
Devin wrote in Now, by the way.
For all the criticisms of David, you're an
opinion show, you're not a news show.
I always want to issue corrections when they
are warranted.
Devin corrected me about PCR tests.
Let's look at what Devin said.
Hello, David.
Sir, I was watching one of your recent videos
on YouTube where you were discussing PCR tests
for COVID.
And you mentioned that the PCR tests detect
viral proteins.
I did say that.
Devin writes, This is technically incorrect.
COVID PCR tests detect the presence of viral
RNA.
I know you pride yourself on disseminating
correct information.
I'd figured you'd want to know you were right,
Devin.
I did want to know.
Love the show.
Keep up the good work.
Thank you.
COVID PCR detects the presence of viral RNA.
I stand corrected and I vow at the altar of
the audience and apologize, the rest of the
analysis was correct in terms of the meaning
the diagnostic value of a PCR test, which
has become unfortunately the subject of yet
more conspiracy theories.
Lastly, Ryan wrote in and says Sir David David,
sir.
Have been a member almost as long as I've
been listening almost a year now.
Greatly appreciate your calm and honest delivery
of the daily topics.
Keep doing what you do.
We all appreciate it.
Not all.
You should see my inbox, but I appreciate
the sentiment.
Over the long weekend, I was listening to
some of your old interviews.
While I appreciate the productive, sane interviews,
I've got to say the ones with quote religious
people are probably the most entertaining.
For example, the David Manning interview is
just a total gem.
Absolutely hilarious.
I suggest the listeners check it out as well.
Thanks for your work.
Happy New Year, Ryan.
Thank you, Ryan.
Yeah, we keep sort of going back and forth
about the value of doing the wacky interviews.
A few months ago, we did one with Amanda Mackey
and she was pretty cuckoo for cocoa puffs.
It does very well.
But the reason I've gotten away from it is
partially it's less entertaining for me.
Like, Yes, these people are bonkers, they're
ignorant.
I get it.
But they're so predictable that I've been
more going in the direction of talking to
journalists, writers, investigators, doctors
ET.
And number two, I don't know.
I know some people in the audience like it.
Some don't.
I'm, as I've said before, will continue to
sprinkle in the interviews with the wacky
people.
But I've explained a little bit of why I've
sort of gotten away from it over the last
few years.
If you have a question for me, a comment,
a thought, whatever you can write into info
at David Pakman dot com.
Remember that if you want to get more show
every day, you should sign up for a membership
at join Packman dot com.
Producer Pat is back from his vacation.
He will be back on the Friday bonus show.
As your regularly scheduled programing has
led you to expect, we will see you on the
bonus show.